the dark knight rises as a pure example  of why i love going to the movies yes  haters this film does have flaws but  this is almost a three-hour epic so when  i look at my list of flaws compared to  everything else i loved about it  greatness outweighs the minor flaws  christian bale is perfect as batman this  is the most human portrayal we've seen  of him yet tom hardy is scary fun badass  fun to impressionate and hathaway's  excellent as catwoman jgl joseph gordon  love it delivers as always this film is  majestic  bold unique more realistic than most  comic book films the cinematography is  just beautiful the production design is  grand the visual and special effects are  top notch the action is exciting the  film is loaded with symbolism and you  get more from this movie with each  viewing experience ryan wright says this  film got it super right